[موسيقى]
وسط ازمه المرور الخانقه جراء الاضراب
احتجبت حتى البرامج الاذاعيه الصباحيه
لسبب ذاته
للعاملين في شبكه اذاعه فرنسا للاضراب في
اطار يوم تعبئه الوطنيه رفضا لاصلاح نظام
التقاعد يتعذر علينا بث كامل برامجنا
المعتاده نلتمس منكم العذر
بسبب الشلل الذي اصابتها نصف شبكه النقل
في فرنسا الاضراب شامل المدارس ومصافي
المحروقات وجميع القطاعات الحيويه من
مولدات الكهربائي والنقل الجوي وحتى موظفي
وزاره الخارجيه
يمسيكي يقعد في نقطه يستعدد خبايا
المصافي لن تجدوا الوقود واضراب عمال
القطار يعني ان لا مجال للتنقل وفي
المدارس كذلك لا تعليم ترونا تداعيات
اليوم ترون ما نثبته لكم اليوم في غيابنا
نحن لا تدور دواليب المجتمع وكل شيء يتوقف
استعراض القوه النقابيه كان اكثر وضوحا في
المظاهره العاريمه التي اجتاحت شوارع
باريس حيث تؤكد النقابات ان قرابه 40%
تظاهروا رمضا لمشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد
رافعين شعارات تتهم حكومه مكروه بخدمه
الراسماليه المتوحشه وتحميل فاتوره
اخفاقاتها للطبقه العامله
كل ساعه
لدينا حظوظ في اي يثمر تحركنا سريعا اي في
ان تتراجع الحكومه عاجلا عن مشروعها امام
تعبئتنا المهمه جدا المؤشرات واضحه على
وجوب ان تسحب الحكومه مشروع الاصلاح هذا
المظاهرات اثبتت ان معارضتها لاصلاح نظام
التقاعد يستند الى دعم شعبي كبير فان
الرئيس مكرون رد بالقوله ان شرعيته
الشعبيه نالها في الانتخابات الاخيره وان
مشروع الاصلاح قدم بطريقه ديمقراطيه وهو
حسب رايه عادل ومسؤول
[موسيقى]
يقول المتظاهرون ان اختبار شرعي اثبت ان
مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد يفتقر الى السند
الشعبي وان الحكومه مطالبه بالاستماع لصوت
النقابيين الرافدين والبحث عن حلول بديله
لطفي المسعودي الجزيره باريس